the Joe Rogan experience so wait so the
the it was on that all talk radio was
that the guy who would was his name who
would he would do all the voices he
would do all the characters no he was on
radio Joe
Phil Henry Hill Hendry Hill Henry wait
ville him he would and he still does it
if you never heard Phil Henry he's a
goddamn genius yeah Phil Hendry would
answer the phone and then he would be
the caller so he would call up with
these ridiculous
he would say ridiculous [ __ ] yeah were
you like how can this guy be real if
people get so angry and then other
people would call in like that man is so
ignorant and then he and you say no
mammies you are ignorant here in front
of the Journal of American medicine and
he would just go on these and most
people were in on the gag Yeah right I
don't even say most people maybe like
60% okay yeah great good being parked in
front of my house like listening to it
like yeah yeah I think he is I think
you're right what does he do these days
does he have a radio show he's probably
well Henry he's probably working with
uncle Floyd Andrew show the Phil Henry
is it on the radio the youtubes about
iTunes I feel about when I hear about
okay that's good when I hear people that
are still doing radio radio Mike Wolfe
do you have any other options is there
other what can you get out I'm on Sirius
XM right now that's different that's
definitely means like translating
interests you like radio like over the
over the air right yeah
I know but you know what there is
something like I've been I was in a
couple towns Columbus Ohio
Denver even where they have a strong
terrestrial radio thing mm-hmm station
that's popular Austin does Austin Bob
it's such a cool thing and we've kind of
lost something like mmm because they're
talking about the show that's coming to
our town ignites a sense of community
that you don't have in other things
right and it's live
yeah it's happening over the air
coming in this weekend we're gonna we'll
be there it was also censored that's a
real issue
yeah for sure I mean look one thing that
we all owe Howard Stern a huge debt of
gratitude is that he was sued by the FCC
yeah I mean like with jibt yeah yeah he
was sued he lost a shitload of money the
the media company was a company that had
his show whenever the company was yeah
they were fined hundreds of thousands of
dollars right for him like well for
almost nothing
this was during the Bush administration
they were going after him remember that
yeah I remember it dude they went after
him they went after him hard to the
point where it was scary yeah we're like
you would you would hear about it you're
like what yeah and and you would hear
about the things that he got fine see if
you can find the things that Howard
Stern about five things you got fine for
yeah let's pull that up rejas listen man
whatever anybody wants to say about
Howard Stern that [ __ ] opened
the door for all of us all of us for me
100% yeah okay let me see like the first
thing is the fart man's done well he got
fine for that that was intelligent ISM
as he showed his ass okay it's not
really surprised that he exposed his
butt cheeks and a $10,000 gold spandex
superhero costume and blah blah blah
where'd where's it's a fine - where's
it's a good fine for that I don't owe
most of the greatest offense he was he
was Aunt Jemima joke yeah well there was
a lot of stuff that he said you know
that you would look at it today like in
terms of like a podcast you'd say listen
there's always a I'm outrageous so
here's the things that he got fine for
let's make that look at the [ __ ]
numbers man August 12th 1993 $500,000
infinity broadcast network all right and
good find $600,000 and $500,000 $600,000
December 18 1992 and then August 12 1993
$500,000 so within a year six months
time even look 92 2004 look at that
is it in one in one year
in six months time they get fired
$1,100,000 [ __ ] insane man well and I
wonder what the offenses were its
language mostly language
I'm sure its language or subject matter
potty humor you know [ __ ] man crazy I
mean we think about this today in terms
of like what we get away with on
podcasts oh god oh my god total freedom
total freedom and I think a lot of that
was open that door was open because of
Howard Stern what does it say that it
says playing the piano with his penis
she recorded that Chris okay Louie Louie
this wjk JFK FM and Washington DC became
the third Infinity station to air the
Howard Stern Show in 1988 two months
later and Stoll Mel of New Jersey
mistakenly tuned her radio to hear Stern
talk about having naked women in for an
upcoming show she recorded the us
[ __ ] snitch she reported the
Christmas party broadcast in December
16th that featured a man playing the
piano with his penis mm-hmm
a choir singing about gay sex to the
tune of white Christmas and women being
hypnotized to achieve orgasm under the
referral of her senator this [ __ ]
crazy lady called the senator and
Congressman stumble fire filed a
complaint with transcripts and a tape of
the program the FCC reviewed the
evidence and asked infinity in October
1989 for an explanation as the material
in quotes may have violated federal law
by including indecent programming during
daytime hours and that funny like at
nighttime it's okay to get naughty yeah
Karmazin argued that the term patently
offensive in its new ruling was vague
and the sexual references cited were no
more offensive than daytime television
shows Geraldo and Donahue which use
similar terms without repercussions sure
his response was later rejected FCC yeah
so they started finding them back
then in 88 I would imagine that for
terrestrial radio a lot of that still
holds don't you could get away with a
lot more now yeah because of him it was
a Howard Stern because of all the I mean
look and he was under the gun manatee he
stuck to his guns yeah he kept doing the
same program I mean it's it's a vastly
different program now but and people
criticize him because of that but look
he's a different person yeah he
shouldn't have to do that old show he's
he should do whatever he wants right
that's who he is now right exactly you
know but I work for NPR they do this
live from here which was Prairie Home
Companion mm-hmm and I do this thing on
that show and there they have comedians
on once in a while and they have
musicians and they are really strict
when when a comic is about to go out
there he's told 20 times what he can and
can't say hmm and it's like really
really really strict and if you violate
it if you say the wrong thing they get a
fine for every station that it airs on
throughout the network
oh yes 100 stations is a hundred fun yes
exactly that is it's still it's still
really serious and that's censorship 6
o'clock in the evening in the East Coast
it's so ridiculous it's you know look I
get it if you have a program and it's a
rated PG program and you know this is
the way you want it because it's for
kids and their families and stuff like
that but for the government to step in
it's ridiculous yeah it really is
ridiculous and the fact that this was
you know that people had to endure this
for so long right I mean like before
Howard Stern people have to realize
there was no one there was no one like
that there was great Don Imus he is kind
of controversial in some ways yeah he
was and then Stern who is just a totally
different animal
yeah he opened the door for podcasts for
sure
yeah all these outrageous people doing
podcasts he made the road map right yeah
100% well show the other was that here's
you can come over to this side of the
street and no one's gonna mess with you
[Applause]